[Music]
all right so today we cancel sesame
street uh we could have canceled sesame
street a week ago when big bird tweeted
big bird has a twitter account now by
the way he tweeted that he'd just gotten
the vaccine despite having natural
immunity
from respiratory viruses due to the fact
that puppets don't have respiratory
systems but i suppose if we're giving
the vaccine to kids who are almost
completely immune to severe coba illness
then we might as well give it to
fictional birds also to make matters
creepier big bird then appeared on a cnn
town hall to further push
pharmaceuticals onto kids
big bird seems to have really settled
into his new role as drug dealer
here's what that looked like
you know my granny bird says that since
i'm six years old i can get the vaccine
oh yeah that's right big bird
but well uh i have a lot of questions
like
what is a vaccine and does it have to be
a shot and and will i still need to wear
my mask those are such great questions
big bird and it turns out lots of kids
and families have questions too so over
the next half hour we're going to be
answering your questions talking with
experts and giving you information you
need about vaccinations for kids
oh um
uh you know what
i'm a better guard change
i'll see you later
[Music]
oh come on it's time for
[Music]
okay this raises um
a number of questions questions like
what the hell happened to big bird's
voice
why does he sound like a child molester
now he's he sounds distinctly creepy all
of a sudden also what kind of six year
old is watching a cnn special about
vaccinations in the first place who is
this
who is the audience for this
when i was a kid the only thing i knew
about cnn was that it's the channel my
dad watches sometimes when he wants to
yell at the tv which come to think of it
explains a lot in any case this is all
very weird and inappropriate and
dystopian and horrible as a show for
preschoolers hawks a drug that nobody in
the preschool demographic actually needs
but that's not why i'm canceling sesame
street
it would have been it would it would
have been the reason until they gave us
a whole new reason
as abc reports quote sesame street
debuts g young the first asian american
muppet that's the headline the article
says at only seven years old g young is
making history as the first
asian-american muppet in the sesame
street canon she's korean-american and
has two passions rocking out on her
electric guitar and skateboarding the
children's tv program which first aired
52 years ago this month gave the ap a
first look at its adorable new occupant
g young will formally be introduced in
see us coming together a sesame street
special simolu padma lakshmi and uh
naomi asaka are among the celebrities
appearing in the special which we'll
drop on thanksgiving now if you want to
see
young in action which i know you do
here she is
actually there's something really cool
about my name
so in korean uh traditionally the two
syllables they each mean something
different and she means like uh
smart or wise and um young means like uh
brave or courageous or strong yeah and i
think it was honestly inspired
unfortunately by um but the past year
and the rise in um you know attacks and
and uh racist incidents against the
asian people especially during covid my
one hope
obviously is to help have chi young help
teach you know
what racism is help teach kids to
be able to recognize it and then speak
out against it but then my other hope
for chiang is that she just normalizes
seeing different kinds of looking kids
on tv and i am excited to share kim pop
and toki and kogi and jiges and panchans
and kimchi and chapchae and and all
sorts of stuff
oh yes okay well we need the asian
muppet to tell kids about racism in case
they didn't pick up on the racism
lessons from literally every other show
or movie they've ever watched it's very
important to see that we don't allow
young children to go more than 17
minutes without being reminded of racism
even 17 minutes is probably too long i'm
concerned that you know
like spaghettios hasn't released a new
product product where
the letters in the soup are r-a-c-i-s-m
so that even when they're eating they
can still be reminded of racism
plus as the as the puppeteer behind the
asian muppet explains we also need to
normalize asian people for kids
this is important in case there are any
children in america who've never seen an
asian person before we need to think
about you know all those kids maybe who
were raised uh inside a crater on the
moon and haven't encountered any members
of another race or ethnicity
we need to make sure we normalize other
ethnicities for all of those moon
children who might be watching but this
all leads to a confusing question
ji young is the first asian puppet on
sesame street
okay
well then what race are the other
muppets
what race is ernie what is elmo's
nationality
where is grover's ancestral home
we know that the count is from
transylvania so we know that uh we know
oscar the grouch is from new jersey
which is why he prefers living in a
trash can but the rest of the characters
seem to be very intentionally non-racial
i mean what the hell is snuffleupagus
supposed to be
does cookie monster have an ethnic
background
i guess he's from new jersey also in
fact he was the governor of the state
from 2010 to 2018 but you see the point
most of these characters have no
ethnicity
no race no nationality they're fictional
fictional characters that all children
can relate to equally and i think that
was sort of the point right
they exist in a fantasy world where
there are no races
and there was a time when this this was
the liberal utopia a world of sameness
where nobody is different everyone is
the same and when it comes to things
like gender that kind of homogenous
ambiguous paradise is still what they
strive for but the realm of race in the
realm of race as equity replaces
equality the pendulum has swung back in
the other direction dramatically and now
rather than than emphasizing
similarities and downplaying differences
the left wants to make sure that
everyone is categorized and labeled and
put into a box
and it makes things even more confusing
because we
our gender is all fluid and there's no
differences and it doesn't matter but in
a way but as far as race goes we are
strictly in our box and we can never
leave it
they want kids to see themselves in
those terms
sesame street actually has been pushing
this message for a little while now they
debut they debuted their first black
muppets a few months ago
and uh here's how those characters
explained race
well it's because the more melanin you
have the darker your skin looks
the color of our skin is an important
part of who we are
but we should all know that it's okay
that we all look different in so very
many
oh
ways
fur is red and soft oh and my hair is
black and curly
things on the outside like our skin
color our hair texture
our noses
our mouths and eyes
make us who we are
many people call this race
our skin color is what makes us who we
are
says the black muppet
as woke sesame street tries its hardest
to ensure that kids see race first and
foremost
uh but our skin color is what makes that
when i was a kid watching sesame street
the message was precisely the opposite
of that
of course the funny thing is you'll
notice um the asian puppet
doesn't actually look or sound all that
asian
and so this is always the conundrum for
the identity box checkers when it comes
to cartoons and puppets they want to
make sure that there's proper
representation but they also can't allow
themselves to be accused of stereotyping
which is a problem because when you're
making a puppet or a or a a cartoon
that's supposed to represent a certain
race
then inevitably by definition there is a
caricature a stereotype
going on
but they can't do that yet they want to
have the representation which just means
that the diverse characters
meant to represent a specific ethnicity
or race end up representing really
nothing and nobody in particular they
want to racial racialize the fictional
world as much as they've racialized the
real world but they can't really do that
because then they'd be engaging in
stereotypes so they're left then with
this weird kind of half measure
which is what wokeness always boils down
to it boils down to incoherence and
weirdness in the end though on a
different note
i'm wondering if we'll see the episode
where the asian puppet ji young
applies for college and is turned down
in favor of the black muppet you know
that that would be you know that's
another important real world lesson
about equity maybe we'll get that as
well um and i look forward to that but
in the meantime
sesame street we must say is canceled if
you enjoyed this video be sure to give
it a thumbs up and share it with all
your friends